انضم إليّ الآن هنري ريس ، لقد كان
الرجل على خشبة المسرح مع رشدي عندما
وقع الهجوم ، وقد أصيب ريس أيضًا
كما ترون ، ريس هو
المؤسس المشارك ورئيس
مدينة اللجوء غير الربحية هنري ، شكرًا
جزيلاً على مجيئك  نحن بشأن
حالتك أولاً ،
أنا بخير ،
يجب أن نشعر بالقلق جميعًا بشأن سلمان
رشدي ،
أليس كذلك؟
كان
مخطئًا
، كان من الصعب جدًا فهم أنه
بدا وكأنه
نوع من المزحة
السيئة ولم يكن لديه أي إحساس بالواقع
، وبعد ذلك
عندما كان هناك دماء خلفه ،
أصبح حقيقيًا
، هل تم طعنك أولاً أم تم ضربك
أولاً أم أنه كان كذلك  اضغط أولاً ،
لا أريد أن أتحدث كثيرًا عن
الأحداث الفعلية نفسها ،
حسنًا ،
كان هناك العديد من الأشخاص الذين حاولوا بعد ذلك
تقديم الإسعافات الأولية ، هل تتذكر ،
هل يمكنك أن تقول ما فعلته في تلك اللحظات أو
ما حدث لك
أه أفضل  لا على ما يرام  لقد كنت
في المستشفى وتمكنت من إعادتك إلى
المنزل في ذلك اليوم وأنت
تتعافى الآن ، هل تمكنت من التحدث إلى رشدي أو
عائلته منذ الهجوم.
هذا صحيح
عندما حدث هذا عندما
قفز هذا المشتبه به إلى المسرح ، هل
فكرت على الفور في
الفتوى الإيرانية ضد روسيا لسنوات بالطبع
كان مختبئًا بعد مرسوم الديون الإيراني
في السنوات الأخيرة أه تعلم
أنه كان أكثر علنية وظهورًا
أنت تعرف الكثير منا ، لقد
خرجنا لتناول العشاء معه ، أنت تعرف
شخصًا معروفًا
ومشهورًا عالميًا ،
لكن هل فكرت على الفور في هذه
الفتوى عندما بدأ هذا يحدث
كما قلت ، لقد
فكرت على الفور بذلك  لقد كان
شخصًا يشير إلى نوع من الإشارة السيئة إليه ،
وليس أنه كان في الواقع هجومًا حقيقيًا
نوعًا من محاكاة ساخرة
، والآن هل تمكنت من التحدث
مع الشرطة ، هل هناك أي شيء يمكنك
قوله عن المشتبه به أو  هل من المفترض ألا
تقول إنني حقًا لا أريد التحدث عن
الأحداث الفعلية التي حدثت هناك ،
حسنًا ،
أخبرنا عن المحادثة التي
كنت ستجريها مع صدئ ، إنه أمر لا يصدق
مدى ارتباطها بهذا الأمر
أن هذا هو ما
أعتقد أن هذا هو
جوهر معنى ذلك الحدث الذي كنا هنا
على وشك التحدث
عن حركة مدينة اللجوء التي
نشأها سلمان رشدي في الواقع أن
التهديد الأصلي
ضده خلال فترة الفتوى هو الذي أدى
إلى  تشكيل من قبل مجموعة من الكتاب
في أوروبا لبدء مدينة اللجوء
وحديثه في بيتسبرغ في عام 1997 الذي
ألهمني وزوجتي لبدء
المنظمة التي نديرها
كمتطوعين وآلاف من
جيراننا الآن يدعمون ويشاركون في
أه
ل  يدافع عن القيم
التي يمثلها لتوفير
الملجأ والأمان للكتاب
أه المعرضين للخطر والذين لديهم
موارد أقل من سلمان راش لديه
وهذا هو النوع الكئيب
من السخرية أو  ربما
نية ليس فقط الاعتداء على جسده ولكن
الاعتداء على كل ما يمثله
ما يجب أن يفعله الكتاب والقادة في
أعقاب هذا الهجوم
أه أعني أعتقد أن الجميع حساسون
ولكن ما يمكننا فعله
هو أن الكتاب والكتاب يمكنهم الاستمرار في
الكتابة
و  اكتب
دون
حسن مع
الحق في أقصى درجات
الصدق وقدرتهم كقراء يمكننا
جميعًا أن نخرج ونشتري كتابًا نشتري
كتابًا بقلم سلمان رشدي هذا الأسبوع ونقرأه ،
يجب أن نواصل الكتب يجب أن نذهب
إلى البرامج العامة في
يجب أن تبدأ الفنون وتلك البرامج
بتذكير بأهمية التعبير الإبداعي في
حياتنا كلها وكيف أنه يجذب
الناس
أه
لمناقشة القضايا المهمة والتفكير في
أشخاص آخرين غير أنفسهم
كما حثنا دائمًا على سرد القصص
تحكي قصصًا أفضل  هذه هي الطريقة
التي تعتقد أن هذا سيكون لها قصة إيجابية
ما حدث يوم الجمعة
أه
هناك قصة إيجابية
للأشخاص الذين ليسوا سمك السلمون آه و ر  قبعة
ننظر إلى هذا ونقول إننا
نعيد تكريسنا للقيم
التي يمثلها إذا أتيت
إلى منطقتنا ، فسترى
أن المنظمة التي ألهمها
قد غيرت حينا ،
فهناك كلمات على أبواب جميع المنازل
هناك حدائق ومباني
مفعمة بالحروف الأبجدية ونقوم بتنفيذ
برامج في الشارع ونقوم بتنفيذ برامج
ومباني كلها مجانية حيث يمكن
للأشخاص من مختلف أنحاء
الحياة المشاركة بطريقة مشتركة في الاختلافات
والآراء وتبادل
وجهات النظر والثقافات  معًا وهذا
يؤدي إلى ذلك
ومرة ​​أخرى من حيث السخرية
أه قبل فترة وجيزة من انطلاقنا على المسرح
كنا نناقش معًا
لتوسيع فكرة مدن اللجوء في الولايات
المتحدة ولذا فنحن أحد
مسؤولينا ونأمل أن يكون أحد الإيجابيين  الأشياء
التي ستأتي من ذلك
هي أنه يمكننا البدء في تحديد
المدن الأخرى والأفراد في
تلك المدن والعمل معهم لإضافة
مدن جديدة للجوء وحماية المزيد من
الكتاب بحيث يحدث هذا لعدد أقل من الأشخاص.
riters حول العالم